well joining me now I talk to a
contributor paulone Adrian political
journalist AIS antina and international
editor Isabelle oop welcome to my
dazzling pack all right Paul I can see
you you you can see raging to go off I'm
ready well I'm intrigued that you've
decided to open this really serious and
sensitive debate by suggesting that
somebody referencing themselves as a cat
equates to a child who is struggling to
understand I didn't I actually separated
identify you heard me separate the two
things
Paul hang on sorry you heard me separate
the two things I read out again reminded
people of the absurdity of a teacher
calling children despicable for saying
it was ridiculous to allow someone to be
a cat and then I said but it also there
are serious issues involving people who
are seriously going through the issue of
transgenderism for real not just a fad
of being a cat and they're different
things they they are completely
different things but but you're opening
with that as if it's somehow something
to be dismissed and somehow to be
treated as a joke and this is my problem
with the guidelines which as a joke
which we have waited for parents being
informed about what their children are
doing at school is not a joke to me I'm
a father of four kids who've been
through school I want to know if one of
my kids suddenly decide to identify as a
cat I want a phone call from the school
right we've waited five years for these
guidelines these guidelines are start
off by saying it's about parents being
first we we're putting parents first yes
that's wrong peers it's not about
parents it's about the child it's about
the vulnerable child need absolutely who
needs the adults around them to support
them during this difficult period for
them what it doesn't need what it
doesn't need is for the child who is
vulnerable to be told no the parent
comes first that's the wrong approach no
the parent does come first until the
child is an adult so Paula if you want
your child to be given medicine at
school if you want them just to have
some cow Poole you have to get
permission that has to to you have to go
through a process I have to sign a form
if I want my child to have cowp at
school for a headache or a s throat or
whatever it is to me it is negligent and
bordering on abusive to allow schools
just to honor a child's wishes to be
known temporarily as something else
without
involving this is where we become
confused with being child focused and
saying that the child gets everything
they want they want that's not what I'm
saying being child focused does not mean
that everything the child says is right
but what I'm concerned about is that
saying parent first means that anything
that the child says is always going to
come second to what their parent want do
you think parents should be cut out
let's make this a lot simpler then do
you think it's okay for parents to be
cut out because that's at the heart of
this absolutely not so they should be
involved then a parent must be
involed we're missing out on a really
important CL here so so even if that the
parent agrees that the child would like
to use a different set of pronouns the
school does not have to abide by that
and it would only be exceptional
circumstances where the school actually
accepts it so at the moment there'll be
loads of a lot of children around the
country who will be going into the
Christmas period now not knowing how
they'll be identified when they going to
school in J they get identified as boy
or girl like the old days why do you
feel like that you don't go in and say
you call me they like Sam Smith no those
days are done P You're shouting he so
stupid sh shout about the fact that the
criminal stats tell us that hate crime
against transgender uh people have gone
up 11% in one year over the last 5 years
it's gone up
186 so what we need to do awful so what
we need to do is prepare hatred towards
trans people is awful but why do you
think that there is so much mockery of
trans people compared to five six years
ago I'll tell you why because they are
fighting ludicrous battles the trans
Lobby over things like demanding the
right of biological males identifying as
trans women compete in sport against
females and the more that happen and
then in Scotland you saw Nicolas
sturgeon lose her job because she was
putting biological male rapists into
female prisons where they could attack
women when this stuff happens the real
victims actually the real victims are
genuine trans people who just want to
have a quiet life who go through a lot
anyway and they just want quiet time and
to be respected and Toler
take care rally the troops rally the
conservative troops and say we're going
to fight the next uh election on the
basis of culture wars and trans it's not
a culture
War not a culture
War I'm sorry Paula I'm sorry but the
issue of biological males competing
against biological females is not a
culture War it is an absolute forfront
assault on women's rights
to why any woman still def this nonsense
ridiculous to me we are talking about
that it's been dismissed we're talking
about schools here and in my opinion
this guidance doesn't actually go
anywhere near far enough what would you
like it to say I think it should be can
I just talk for one second here because
I have tried to interject repeatedly and
only been taught down I don't think it
needs to be guidance I think it needs to
be the actual law I do not think schools
should have a huge amount of discretion
or indeed any discretion over this and
by the way this is only a consultation
so we've waited all these months you say
it's years it's certainly nine months
since rishy sunite called for Urgent
action and it's only a consultation look
for me this is very straightforward I do
not think children should be encouraged
to take decisions that they may come to
regret very dreadfully a lot of this
stuff is as we saw the CL right but
these are the arguments that were used
against children in the ' 80s and the
'90s when we were talking about you know
whether children could be gay we were
talking about that you know it's exactly
the same sort of rhetoric should be
talking about social transition being
gay is a sexuality no but right
identifying as a cat is not a sexuality
come on you know that that is a false
equip Mass we discussed how we were not
going to equate that we weren't going to
use the cat analogy with very serious
disc at the moment we've got a murder
trial going on you know potentially
because of a trans child died all right
you know and we're talking about bully
also be murder trials this year of trans
people killing people so it works both
ways no no no come on because okay we
can't talk about that specific you take
you can take out individual stories of
course you can and amplify them no if a
child was but I think I think both of
those are horrific for different reasons
so what does it but trans murderers do
not represent trans people but if a
child was killed because they are trans
then that is pretty important what's
that got to do with the school let me
tell you what is bullying them then
obviously that is all you know that's
allowing that behavior I don't see how
it's going to change bullying we know
how we know how important schools are of
course they are the Locust parenti
aren't they for our children when we
send them off in the morning we know
that and so what's really important of
course is that the school has guidelines
but what happens is rules not guidelines
and you know what that is where I would
app I would agree with you on because at
the moment we don't have anything
watertight it's very fluid we have this
consultation period it's 12 weeks it's a
little bit convenient that they suddenly
sent out these guidelines when most
schools have broken up when most schools
are coming to the end of of their
holidays so what what they think that
they're going to get back you know I
tell you what's been going on Paula
there are no doubt there are some
children genuinely going through
transgenderism right they believe
they're born in the wrong body and they
have to be taken care of cared for
respected and everything I totally
support that uh but there are a very
very small number of people what has
happened in the last 2 to three years
there's been an
explosion in people identifying as
nonbinary gender fluid 100 other genders
because it's it's trendy it's a fad and
teachers have been troduced into going
along with this and not telling parents
and it's completely outrageous my family
are teachers my friends are teachers and
I spoke to them before I came on this
program and I said do you do you have
transgender children at your school and
they said yes I said do you use their
pronouns they all said yes and I told
them about this new guidance and I said
well that's unworkable and why would we
do that to how many have they got what
how many have they got how many trans
very small each but probably one one to
each what about the people identifying
as non-binary gender fluid blah blah
blah but so what there was one school in
Brighton where there were thousand
pupils I think was something like 300
identifying as non-binary or gender Fu
non I'm sorry I don't think it is a so
what I think that when people start
having actual surgery to change their
bodies in ways not reversible that isn't
a shrug shrug so we're
talking Clinic was was created on the
alar of virtue signaling nonsense
and children were being mutilated at
that Altar and it's completely
outrageous what was going on there
that's very different to people using
pronouns well it's a slippery slope
isn't it once you start to acquest to
kids wanting the rights to everything
and they rule the roost and they have
the final say to be comfortable in their
own body parental rights should be
absolutely Paramount now there is an
exception where there's a genuine belief
based on teacher knowledge Social
Services maybe whatever of violence
towards a child who may say something
like that when they go home that is
different and that's been allowed for in
this no it no this guidance specifically
says as well even if it's agreed by the
parents and by the school the school
will not take it on they there's a
specific criteria for kids who may be at
risk right teachers will be able to
withhold information if they believe a
child could be put at significant risk
so it's in there unusual can I just tell
you that isn't unusual in terms of
safeguarding that's quite normal
teachers are always very careful to
ensure that the child comes comes first
and if there is a concern about risk of
harm significant harm then they will of
course do what they need to do in terms
of contacting the appropriate
professionals to ensure that the child
is cared for first before the parent
finds out that's not unusual what my
concern is is exactly what you've just
been amplifying this parental right over
the child right no that's no AB not yes
until they're legal adults the parent
has the right that's his own job this
this is why I'm glad we're actually
having this debate and this needed and
the consult period is required but what
we should not be doing is adding Flames
to this culture War because it's not a
culture War you are doing that it's
about our children we' had Ken B say
that there is no child born in the wrong
body how can you tell me if you had your
way if you had your way you'd have kids
young girls at school I've got a
12-year-old daughter right you'd have
her up against 6'5 in biological males
in Sp you'd have having to share the the
toilets bathrooms with biological males
you'd have a bunch of her friends
identifying as cat you know what it is
it is licensed chaos and actually
bordering on abuse I think it is
bordering on abuse I think that we will
look back on this era in future as a
period in which we allowed our we
actually encouraged children to become
incredibly confused and it is terrible
for mental health to keep projecting all
this oh you might be this you might be
that look the vast vast majority of
people are either a boy or a girl and
they don't need their mind befuddled
with a what we don't need what we don't
need is a people like Sam Smith who
started off as a gay man A year later
he's non-binary then he wants to be
called they them then he wants to be
gender fluid blah blah blah it is just
faddism fism and he Dem by the way let's
not forget that this year thanks to him
and his campaign he demanded the Brit
Wars go gender neutral and what happened
in the best individual singer category
they're all Bloks the nominees look all
men on page one of that guidance it
questions whether gender dysphoria is
even legitimate it questions whether you
know someone can't be born into the
wrong body maybe more maybe more
questions should be asked simply going
I'm a I'm actually I'm a girl I'm a boy
when you're not but no one's splitting
like that we're talking about people who
genuinely feel like they're
B because they're they're all chasing a
f it's just like in the 70s when David
Bowie put makeup on they all wore makeup
kids do that anyway kids also are
suicide peers also self Haring
peers don't and
we and not come across as if we know
what they're not getting because so many
kids are being encouraged to identify as
any the ones who really need help are
getting lost in the wash so you said
that there are ones that really need
help so do I I said that in my all right
I'm glad we all agreed uh nice to see
you
all